the new movie is called luckiest girl
alive it's very powerful
um could you set up a little of this
story for everybody so it's essentially
about perception and reality a little
bit right like that's the best way that
it can describe it and there's often
times and I've said this before and I'll
say it again there was an Onslow of
films and books that were written over
the past couple years of a girl who dot
dot dot like you know and then some sort
of Thriller immerses and what I
personally loved about this so much is
that it is partially based on the
writer's life there's aspects of it that
are pulled from her life so just
devastating devastating but also
prevents people from being like well
that would never happen yeah but that's
not how it would happen and you're like
well but it did yeah and so that to me
was really important
um the other thing was the book uh was
written by Jessica Knoll the script was
written by Jessica Knoll and so often
usually they have screens that never
happens I mean very rarely I shouldn't
say never but but very rarely does it
happen and just did every single right
rewrite every single draft every single
word is Jess's word
um so that I loved but I also love the
fact that there was just this
counter-intuitive voiceover that
happened throughout the film and so
often voiceovers are done as devices of
like helping the story move along and in
this case it's almost the opposite
um it's just like an internal inner
dialogue of what the character is
constantly battling of like what is
happening inside of her versus what
she's projecting to society so you're
also a producer um on the film so this
deals with tough topics so why did you
do you like talking about the tough
topics or because it's kind of
challenging it could be challenging I do
I there's like I think a part of me that
has
um control issues oh right like I like
to be I like to have control yeah and I
so rarely have control as an actor I
mean by so rarely you never really do
you put out a product and then you walk
away and then there's like a whole other
team that comes in and Frankenstein sit
together markets it a certain way and
you have little to no say what happens
after you walk offset and I think an
artist and a musician it is exactly it's
not now but in the beginning in the
beginning you sing the song You Don't
Own It you have no like yes it's a lot
of things passed off yeah exactly so for
like being after a certain period of
being in this industry I was like wait
now I want to be able to have at least
input so that I can't put blame on
anyone else other than myself like I
want to take ownership if something goes
wrong and so when it came to this and
four good days I was like God there's so
many ways to talk about really important
topics without making it feel like
they're being talked at you and I was
like I'm in a position where I can
actually try to do it and if I do it
wrong then it's on me and that's okay
but what I don't want to do is do a
project where it's on me but I didn't
have any control of it yeah that sucks
when the ship is sinking and you're like
it wasn't me but they're like I don't
care yeah but this way it's super fun
yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]